hoffentlich überrascht mich jetzt nicht
das war natürlich schade
mit 31 sekunden es geht also auch
geister vorsicht vorsicht
soz s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer runde survival games nach langer
ender games zeit sind wir heute mal
wieder soweit wir zocken die schwerter
und lassen die kängurus tiefe zu hause
mit dabei ist dennoch legen los ja ich
habe auch jetzt bekommen läuft bei mir
alte ich hatte den schlechtesten
jahrtausends und dann öffentlich noch
eine kiste so also ganz hast dich und
sie einfach noch ein eisen schwert raus
aber ich hab gar nicht erwarten dass sie
mit lohn japan ist 12 22h de.com boxee
box nicht direkt hinter dir
glonass flores alter floor ist mal
wieder hören wir machen hier die
kaputten der zeit
ich habe gerade irgendwie so leicht
königs bild also im sinne von legic wo
bist du er ist der komplett behindert
also so ein vitales menschen habe ich
selten gesehen
hier warte der hat mich einfach er sieht
man eisen schwert und hättet mich mit
der faust als ich mal jetzt neue fans
aber warum das verstehst sich mir nicht
ganz kommen hier unter regierungen meine
steuern die route die habe ich glaube
ich noch nie gezeigt euch zuschauern
sozusagen jetzt first time premiere ihr
seht wo ich immer langweilig ist das
heißt ihr könnt jetzt noch besser tagen
hab ich grad besser gesagt warum sage
ich besser
nein spaß ich weiß ja meine zuschauer
werden so was nie machen weil die
richtige balance seid ihr wisst was ich
gehört
so ist das ja so richtig karte wieder
hat da hinten tag sagt bogan frau
barbara alter dieser anfangs war echt
klasse lief bei uns ist so weit reisen
stellt weiß sie selten das ist stimmt
ich habe gar nicht realisiert bisher
immer weiter ins gehabt ja und ich habe
mir am anfang zwei kitze begriffen das
läuft jetzt wird's halt rüstungs mäßig
noch ein bisschen besser equipment
glaub ich den besten hinterher ich habe
keine ahnung von der karte der erste
kind aber ich gut also der dämmer da ich
habe erst gestern zum ersten mal
wirklich so videos von pvp spiel
angeschaut sowie 56 bisschen länger
vorbei geschaut und da ist mir zum
ersten mal das wort flawless über den
wirklich drauf und das finde ich
ziemlich geil also klar nein nein was
denn ein alter was hast du bekommen
ja was ist das für eine runde altintop
wir hätten doch weitermache oder soweit
den achten dreier in einer runde junge
krank und vor allem alle aus fertig das
die küste gezogen
hier musst du jetzt scheiße jetzt habe
ich alle eisenstädter auf den grenzen
aus der ganzen runde hier ja auf dem vom
ganzen server damit kann das allerdings
anderen runden abgezogen sind jetzt nur
bei uns hier und sagen jetzt sind wir
fast so weit dass wir mal leute halten
können oder jo wirklich ich bin noch nie
im gebäude
ich komme jetzt hinter dir her okay ich
war schon mal los ich bereit in rage
modus dass gute qualität immer so einen
hunger arbeiten da kann man direkt eine
melone essen ja gut melonen sind attacke
also finde ich zumindest weil diese
verdammt wenig auffüllen ein bisschen
witz lang
ich bin gerade richtig sportlich versuch
gab mal nach den links zu schauen
na gut ich komme ich gleichzeitig andere
gegner reinbekommen stop stop me von ein
dass man nicht stoppen
karl schmid würdig sind hinter dir da
ist ja politik
schlecker ihn ab mit einem weißen
schwert der während richtig weit weg ist
ich hätte ich sehen wollte nahm aber
jetzt sind eine verfolgungsjagd wir
geben würde
der rennt aber 5 modus mich nicht alles
täuscht den kopf im nacken
die so rennt man sehen zu können was
hinter einem ist sich kaufmann der seite
da er genau die arme
bitter bitter bitter weil ich es mal
voran lässt doch stehen jung hat ich
habe mir immer eine heiße 14 tage laufen
hatte ich gut erwischt ja scheiße svp sg
und der machte tolerant aber sagen
bergen bodenschatz soll das herzalter
omaha de hallo ein halbes herz dass die
htg im jahr
das war auch richtig einbuße mich so
hoch und ich falle von oben auf ihn
drauf und gebe ihm den feind in berlin
saubere sache wir müssen aber echt
malzeug wegwerfen hier
ich hab jetzt auch bogen mitfeiern
brauchst du viel oder am boden fällt der
fakire anpacken will ich auf jeden fall
nehmen und hier
ich habe sogar noch ausgenommen die eher
zufällig da wäre die schwerter runde des
todes dafür richtig krank
ok ja freiwillig nehmen
hab ich dir schon gehen ja hab ich so
schnell bin wie us recht okay krass
alles klar dann war's dann lassen wir
jetzt mal richtig aus coupé 5 modus ist
ja nicht so machen
siehst du da hat mein kopf im nacken wir
mal so hinter sich schaut denn
eskalieren wir jetzt mal richtig
wir können uns jetzt mal
wir müssen jetzt auf jeden fall den
nächsten gegner finden für jeden halter
um die killing spiel weiter zu führen
dürfen nicht abheben
das kostet ja das ist ja dass wir zwei
richtige normal runden jetzt haben ja
erst richtig lustig euro könnt ihr uns
wissen wahrscheinlich da oben hier oben
so viele wie jetzt nicht mehr probieren
wie fertig gibt's eigentlich in der
runde
außer uns ja das heißt ein nutzer noch
kräftig skm der bach walther
bester thw lesen sie jetzt auch zuerst
mal also sonst immer irgendwie sg
hoechst feuchte gehören
wo also was ist ein junger ich habe
einfach nur 7 xp ist also jetzt noch
jetzt habe ich schon level hat noch vier
stück heißt wir können auch alle
entscheiden meist aberwitzigen dass man
so spät vielleicht sind die leute die
gerne mal leute
und müssen doch langsamer welche sein
ist okay jetzt daumen drücken
daumendrücken daumen drücken ja ich hab
das ja ich kann es mir experten zu
setzen ich habe noch im april schwer
genau die tauschen werden ist leider das
mitbekommen aber ich könnte vielleicht
noch reichen für eine weitere
verzögerung ein bisschen glück
ich habe auch kein winter sein das ist
egal was wir nicht haben
schade ich habe aber leider auch kein
experte ich hatte sieben stück krass und
nama hubkraft ganz normaler tag im leben
eines mini kraft die sie mit fernglas an
sehe aber auch kein ich auch nicht ich
versuche ganz megamäßig hierzu streifen
war das so geil aus das zeug ist zwar
einfach noch nicht geändert aber das
verschwinden zu langsam nebel da rechts
ich weiß nicht was du den rändern
distance hast ich hab doch auf 12 und
die ja recht sieht so richtig ja müsste
möchte ich habe glück ich immer so
eingestellt läuft jetzt mehr von
schadenswert fans reisen steht auch
richtig geil aus man sicht ok so ja
nicht aber so was hast du für technische
pack ich habe für mich irritiert dass
jacksons wächst ständig
von hinten hat er so lange ich mach
kaputt ist
weg blockiert aber jetzt muss man
schauen dass wir um wegkommen ich bin
weit gehenden gestorben aber der selbst
nicht mehr viel leben haben okay der
ärzte kann jetzt den kopf wieder nutzen
also auf geht's erst kommt kommt kampf
kampf kampf kampf kampf kommt kann kommt
ich habe gerade die ersten mal in meinem
in meinem leben glaube ich eine aufnahme
geblockt habe ich vorher noch nie
gemacht aber ich bin gerade dabei ein
bisschen man pvp zu arbeiten
dunkel
ich sehe nichts also ihr sieht
wahrscheinlich schon was in der aufnahme
aber das display reflektiert bin mir so
krass hoffentlich überrascht mich jetzt
nicht
das war natürlich schade dass techniker
30 sekunden ist diese idee sie
unterstützen aber dass er sauber
gekommen und will ich sagen oder
gestreift wie er so nennen wollte
eiskanal auf infor läuft das geht
natürlich gespannt wie es in der aa
ausrangiert gegen den 1
richtig los da nicht mal die rüstung
lockeres lied war läuft bei mir richtig
geil
alles klar ich würde sagen wenn ich die
runde gefallen hat dann las einen daumen
nach oben
jack marr es ab der es in der
beschreibung und wie immer anmerkungen
alle anderen sachen in die kommentare
dann sehen was beim nächsten video
wieder macht's gut haut rein und ciao